.
I GUESS WE ARE STARTING.
ALL RIGHT, I AM LAURA INGRAHAM,
THIS IS "THE INGRAHAM ANGLE"
LIVE FROM THE PATRIOT AWARDS IN
HOLLYWOOD, FLORIDA.
WE HAVE A BANG UP SHOW TONIGHT.
SOME OF YOUR FAVORITE GUESTS ARE
JOINING US HERE ON SET.
BUT FIRST, ALL RIGHT, NOW THAT
THE DUST HAS SETTLED ON THE
MIDTERMS, I WANT TO SUMMARIZE
WHERE WE ARE.
OKAY.
FIRST, THE SUPREME COURT
OVERTURNED ROE VS. WADE EARLIER
THIS YEAR, AND THAT ACCOMPLISHED
A DECADE-LONG GOAL GOAL FOR THE
G.O.P.
NUMBER TWO, THE REPUBLICANS TOOK
THE HOUSE AND NANCY PELOSI'S
POLITICAL CAREER IS EFFECTIVELY
OVER.
NOW MORE ON THAT LATER.
THIRD, JOE BIDEN'S APPROVAL
RATING IS BARELY ECLIPSING 40%
RIGHT NOW.
UNBELIEVABLE.
AND FOURTH, JPMORGAN IS
PREDICTING JUST A MILD RECESSION
IN 2023.
NOTHING TO WORRY ABOUT AT ALL.
AND FIFTH, REPUBLICANS ARE IN
GOOD SHAPE FOR 2024.
RON DeSANTIS IS BETTING THE
BETTING FAVORITE TO WIN THE
WHITE HOUSE WITH TRUMP CLOSE
BEHIND.
SO I JUST LAID ALL OF THAT OUT
FOR YOU, AND THE DEMOCRATS THINK
THEY ARE DOING GREAT?
OH, OKAY.
WELL, THE TRUTH IS THAT DESPITE
THESE INDIVIDUAL RACES THAT DID
NOT GO THEIR WAY, REPUBLICANS
ACTUALLY PERFORMED REMARKABLY
WELL IN THE MIDTERMS.
IN FACT, THEY DID SO WELL
"THE WASHINGTON POST" ADMITTED
IN A PIECE THIS MORNING THAT
THEY WILL END UP WITH A SMALL
MAJORITY BUT TO THAT UNEXPECTED
RESULT BRINGS A BROADER MOVEMENT
TO THE RIGHTS WHEN COMPARING
VOTES IN EACH DISTRICT TO THE
PRESIDENTIAL VOTE TWO YEARS AGO.
NOW GET THIS, REPUBLICANS OUT TO
RAN 20 MARGINS IN 334 DISTRICTS.
BY COMPARISON.
DEMOCRATS OUTPERFORMED TO
JOE BIDEN IN JUST 69 DISTRICTS.
SO WHAT DOES THAT AMOUNT TO?
IT CURRENTLY REPUBLICANS ARE
LEADING DEMOCRATS NATIONWIDE BY
MORE THAN FOUR POINTS.
AND WE ALL KNOW HOW MUCH THE
LEFT LOVES THAT METRIC.
>> ONCE AGAIN LAST NIGHT THE
DEMOCRATS WON THE POPULAR VOTE
AGAIN.
>> SOME HISTORIC NUMBERS IN THE
POPULAR VOTE FOR THE MIDTERMS.
>> DOESN'T MATTER, FOR ARGUMENTS
ABOUT LEGITIMA